wer ist der Hacker komm hier direkt die
erste Frage wir werden euch gleich alles
sagen wir machen Server sind Sana du
kannst ja schon mal erklären was war im
letzten Stream los auf jeden Fall war es
letztes Mal so dass ganz urplötzlich die
hieß ne
auf einmal eine dritte Person auf
unserem Server war
so hä und dann war deine ganz schwarze
Person und dann haben wir uns natürlich
erstmal gefragt wer es war der hat uns
dann bedroht äh wollte dass du den 1000
€ geben weil der irgendwie Lukas Server
keine Ahnung ja erzähl weiter Laser ja
also wir waren auf dem Server und
wollten ganz normal spielen ich hatte
auch eigentlich was cooles vorbereitet
womit ich dann da reinlegen wollte das
hat jetzt leider dann letztens ziemlich
geklappt wir waren
[Musik]
lachen muss trotzdem und haben dann
gesehen dass
eine dritte Person mit auf dem Server
war weil als wir schlafen gehen wollten
stand dort drei Spieler dann haben wir
uns halt gedacht okay wer ist das oh ich
habe aber 25 TNT durch ihn bekommen weil
er sich ja gecheatet hatte sehr geil
die behalte ich vielleicht besser
erstmal
ein bisschen Stress gemacht hat Sandra
geschlagen hat unser Boot abgebaut als
wir abhauen wollten und hat vor allem
halt auch irgendwelche Nachrichten
geschrieben so von wegen ey ich weiß wer
ihr seid blablablabla wir dachten halt
wir wurden irgendwie gehackt weil wir
den Server wenn die Traum raus und haben
und vielleicht wenn jemand die
einlogdaten hat oder wir die aus
Versehen mal gezeigt hatten oder
irgendwie sowas der kann das natürlich
passieren dass dann Leute drauf joinen
ich hatte auch keine whitel ist drauf
weil ich dachte hey okay unnötig so ähm
jeder der die App soll halt drauf joinen
können so
hat halt keiner die IP und dann dachte
ich erst so verdammt vielleicht hat sie
irgendeiner rausgefunden ich wollte dann
direkt eine Whitelist drauf machen das
hat mich geklappt weil ich nicht mehr
Operator war und ich konnte nicht mehr
darauf zugreifen ich dachte dann es gibt
nur drei Möglichkeiten entweder es ist
einer aus der Community also von euch
von den Zuschauern vielleicht dann das
Bruder Malik hätte sein können weil der
damals immer Zugriff auf den Server
hatte weil Sandra über den Account von
Mali gespielt hat früher hieß Sandra
noch in den ersten Folgen wenn ihr euch
auf Youtube noch mal anschaut kommentari
und deswegen dachte ich es wäre
vielleicht Malik der seine Account Namen
geändert hat und drauf gejoint ist dann
haben wir allerdings angerufen Malik
meint er was nicht dann habe ich gedacht
das war Siri und das hätte auch Sinn
ergeben weil mit Sirio hatte ich damals
diesen Server bevor wir Minecraft loser
gemacht haben weil Siri und ich dort
privat Minecraft gezockt haben einfach
so auf lache ihr kennt das vielleicht im
Winter denkt man sich dann so für eine
Woche wiederkommen dass Minecraft
spielen wir haben Serie bei Facebook
angerufen Siri lag auf dem Sofa und hat
eine Serie geguckt oder FIFA gezockt
oder irgendwie so ein war auch bei
Minute 80 also ähm weil jetzt nicht dass
er jetzt irgendwie gerade sich gedacht
da komme ich halt mal ganz kurz an dann
haben wir erstmal gedacht okay es ist
niemand den wir kennen Scheiße lass mal
kurz mit dem Typen schreiben haben wir
mit dem hier ein bisschen geschrieben
beim Chat ist das gemacht bisschen
versucht herauszufinden wer ist oder was
er halt vor allem will kann halt
irgendwie nicht so richtig bei raus er
hat uns seine ganze Zeit verfolgt und
dann haben wir irgendwann gesagt als
keine Antwort kam kommen wir gehen
offline scheiß drauf Sandra und ich
haben danach noch telefoniert haben
darüber gesprochen ob wir die Polizei
anschalten was wir machen wie was wo
Pipapo weil wenn das jetzt jemand ist
der irgendwie Zugriff auf WhatsApp hat
weil wir haben uns auf WhatsApp halt die
IP geschickt und alles mögliche und der
hatte hört sich auch eine Nachricht
gewusst wie wir uns geschickt haben das
war vielleicht Zufall also es war
wirklich Zufall da kommen wir gleich
aber da dazu noch mal und dann hast du
ja sogar mir geschrieben dass du eine
Nachricht geschickt bekommen hast von
einem User der
herausgefunden hat wie man bei Minecraft
sieht
welchen Namen die Person schon mal hatte
genau ich habe quasi eine DM bekommen
weil ich bin erstmal alle die Ems
durchgegangen weil ich dachte okay
vielleicht hat die Person mir privat
oder so noch mal geschrieben und ähm
dann schick mir quasi eine Person hey
ich habe herausgefunden welcher Name der
User davor hatte und wer war
Sirio 01 wir blenden euch also für die
die gerade das Youtube Video schauen wir
blenden euch hier mal den Screenshot ein
im Livestream kann ich das
logischerweise gerade nicht machen aber
was ich ihm gleich machen kann
als furzen ne mich wusste es gerade mit
den Screenshot eingeblendet jemand hat
herausgefunden wenn man ultimate Venom
auf seiner Minecraft Username Website
Statistik control keine Ahnung was
eingibt steht dort frühere usernames
Sirion 01 haben wir erstmal Siri damit
konfrontiert und er meinte dann nur so
weil wir haben vorher zusammen in der
Dreierkonstellation Mario Party gespielt
Sirio meinte dann als wir meinen wir
gehen jetzt in Minecraft drüber meinte
er ja okay ich gehe jetzt offline Ciao
er hat sich dann aber wahrscheinlich
gedacht vorher schon ey ich gehe jetzt
mit rein in Minecraft und verarscht die
ein bisschen deswegen drücken es war
Sirio was natürlich wir schon auch
gedacht hatten weil es ist in meiner
Ansicht nach hinten ist nur sie oder
Malik sein können und es ist zum Glück
jetzt nicht krass passiert Leute aber
ich hatte Angst tut mir leid kann man
nichts machen ja Leute also es war Sirio
es war eine sehr krasse Idee dafür muss
man wirklich Props geben plus er hat
nichts kaputt gemacht also ich fand es
waren sehr sehr cooler prank von Siri an
uns das war schon sehr sehr wild ich
habe jetzt eine Server drauf das heißt
niemand kann joinen ich habe jetzt die
ganzen sicherheitssachen gemacht
und Sirio kann auch weiterhin joinen mit
dem Ultimate Venom Account also wenn er
Bock hat kann er weiterhin drauf joinen
und ab und zu uns mal einen Besuch
abstatten also das war kein Hacker
sondern es war Siri oder die dir die
einloggt hat noch hatten aber ich habe
jetzt sowohl Malik als auch Sirius alten
Account rausgenommen ultimate Venom kann
uns noch einen Besuch am statten aber ja
ähm ich habe gerade jemand gefragt was
war der prank den du eigentlich geplant
hattest für die Folge kann ich jetzt ja
mal sagen weil es hat nicht geklappt
leider und zwar falls sich übrigens
irgendjemand von euch mit Servern und
Mods auskennt also Modifikationen nicht
Mods jetzt im Sinne vom Chat
Moderatoren sondern wirklich Mods dann
schreibt mir mal bitte bei Instagram
oder irgendwie so oder auf dem discord
Server oder oder weil dann könnten wir
hier auch Mods drauf installieren wie
zum Beispiel eine Minimap Mod oder
irgendwie sowas das wäre eigentlich sehr
sinnvoll und dann hört mich jetzt gerade
nicht aber vielleicht doch diese dauert
wir wollten eigentlich kann ich euch
jetzt auch sagen ein prank machen ja wir
wollten mal drauf machen jetzt schon
jemand erraten
mein meine prank Idee war Morph
modification das heißt ich kann sagen ey
ich bin jetzt ein Schwein und dann habe
ich die Form und die Größe eines
Schweines und kann einfach zu Sandra
hinlaufen und sie schlagen als Schwein
[Musik]
heute wird nichts gesprengt und haben
wir hoffentlich mal wieder eine schöne
selfie was angetreten
was hat mich denn schon wieder gemacht
was
[Musik]
ist das ein itemrahmen
Rüstungen
[Musik]
unter Glocke
ich kann dir helfen
[Musik]
ich habe die Werkbank nicht
selfie
doch
[Musik]
Leute was geht
liebe Grüße peace Leute was geht ab naja
Leute das war der Stream mit dem Hacker
können wir sehr sehr sehr froh sein dass
wir dort nur von Sirio gehackt wurden
und jetzt nicht noch mehr passiert ist
also Leute haut rein macht's gut wir
sehen uns entweder morgen oder keine
Ahnung wann folgt mir auf Twitch dann
kriegt sie direkt eine Benachrichtigung
wenn ich online gehe
[Musik]